today i'm going to talk about quarks
you've probably heard about quarkx's
elementary particles but i'd like to
introduce you to a simpler quark here it
is it is a
central european cheese it's a curd
cheese very popular in germany so this
is
my version of clarks i'm going to talk
about what the evidence is for quarks
because you've never seen one apart from
this
that's the first time you've seen it
in fact
a theory of quarks was invented by two
different people at the same time
one of the big things that we try and do
in
physics is to work out the building
blocks of nature what are the the lego
bricks from which everything else
emerges you know whether it be the
chairs in the room
the doors you and i before the sixes we
just thought about elementary particles
as being protons and neutrons with
electrons whizzing around them and the
protons and the neutrons are the
smallest known particles and they seem
to be elementary but um gradually
as more and more experiments were being
done in the turn of the century and into
the
1920s we began to realize there were
other phenomena occurring which you
wouldn't have expected if the neutrons
and the protons were the basic building
blocks now in 1964 independently two
guys came up with the idea that the
protons the neutrons weren't elementary
they were made up of three other little
particles whizzing around each other
these particles were called aces by
george zweig
but history has forgotten him more or
less the other person murray gale mann
called them quarks
apparently it's to do it came from the
from
the quark came from the quack of a duck
okay so that's where he he knew he
wanted something like that
and originally he thought about the
sound of a quacking duck and he wanted
it to be called quack quack
um i know that the na so the name quarks
was uh uh came from murray gal man i
mean he's a very special man
murray kelman one of the brightest
people i've ever
come across and
he he invented the name and he had read
work by james joyce an irishman
a poet somebody who was a really
wonderful writer and there was this
quotation in his work finnegan's wake
which is almost unreadable three quarks
on mr mark
three quarks
for
um
um
and he used this idea of quark as the
basis of a very erudite particle
muster mark three quarks for muster mark
and i think it was simply that the three
was there
and the quarks were there and that
sounded like quack and he wanted the
three because if you remember he thought
there was the up the down and the
strange and it all fitted beautifully so
you have these two different things and
aces is much simpler but corks
well that's what we've ended up with
now the trouble with this picture of
quarks is that
normally when you want to find out what
something is made of you build a bit of
lego and you want to find how it's done
you smash it to pieces and put it
together again well you try to do the
same things with protons and neutrons to
see if it's made of three particles and
they stick together with such strong
forces the more you pull away the more
they want to stick together so it seemed
impossible to get any experimental
evidence for the existence of these
particles at all
and they fell into disrepute
the third stage of the story is a famous
scientist called richard fryman
a theoretician goes and sees the people
doing experiments in which electrons are
bashing into protons
and he looks at the results and realizes
that he's got a way of thinking about it
that will give evidence for the
existence of these particles within the
proton
and the way he imagines it
involves relativity which is a weird
subject but if you could imagine sitting
on the electron and traveling at near
the speed of light
any object you see instead of being
round becomes squashed like a pancake
and as such it becomes a two-dimensional
object
and they call it pancakes inside this
two-dimensional object there are three
different blobs that are visible
to the electrons and they smash into one
blob another blob or another blob and
you can analyze the results of the
electron scattering and how it bashes
into this and scatters off just by
imagining there are three parts to this
which will scatter
that was the smoking gun with that they
had actually seen quarks separate
entities but he didn't want to call it
quark straight away because he was a bit
more devilish than than
uh most people
highly intelligent but he had a wicked
sense of humor and didn't like to be
bested so he imagined there were three
parts in this and instead of calling
them quarks
he called them part-ons
and probably did that to wind his
colleague murray gail mann up because
they were polar opposites in character
whereas dick fireman will wear shirt
sleeves and dressed like this
marigold man will wear tweed and
really be respondent whereas murray girl
man would go to the faculty club and
have
nice lunches on perfect plates he would
go down to the greasy spoon and have a
hamburger they were complete opposite
characters and didn't get along at all
and both are absolute geniuses and
they shared the same secretary
they lived they had their two officers
and then in between them they had the
secretary and both had a door into her
office
and the people didn't know how to talk
to these two guys in the same department
because they were using different names
and it might get confusing but
eventually marigold man one out and
everybody has called them quarks the
proton is made it's not as simple as the
original picture was because in the
original picture excuse me i'm going to
take this slice of apricot off and
divide this up into three so let's have
three quarks there's one bit of quark
over there look how easy they are to
separate in this model and there's
another one and there's a third so in
the original model put forward by murray
girl man they were just these three
which have different flavors so this
flavor is just a word and this one is
called up
the next one is called down and the next
one is called strange because it was
totally unexpected when it turned up and
originally
gelman thought they were just these
three later on people found that a more
consistent picture would come if we
divided these into two
and imagine there were six of them
so now we get to the stage where there
are six quarks there's an up and a down
and this is called the first generation
because they're the low energy ones
this is the second generation they're
higher energy and they took longer to
appear this is a strange and a charm
quark
and then later on there was a bottom and
a top quark and this was found in 1995
quite recently
in my lifetime it seems just the other
day
and that is the current standing on the
quarks that there are these six quarks
they come in three families or
generations
uh you have the
up and the down form one you have the
charm and the um
strange from the second one and you have
the top and the bottom form the third
and they have very similar properties
except basically as you go from
right to left from the up
and then to the charm and then to the
top
the masses of these particles increase
and in fact the top quark
is something like uh let's see it's 170
what a stupid thing i'm about to try and
do
the up quark is about 2 million electron
volts and the top quark is about 170
billion electron volts
so it's roughly 10 to the 5 10
100 000 times more massive than the up
so now we believe there are just these
six quarks but who knows if they go to
higher energy
oh that tastes good there could be
others